بما ان الكلام عن اكتئاب الشتاء ها انا
انتقلت من موسكو الى استوديو صباح العربيه
بحثا عن القليل من نور الشمس والقليل من
الدف دفئوا الطبيعه في الخليج العربي ودف
الزمالك في هذا البرنامج ولكن لنتكلم
قليلا عن شتاء موسكو تخيل ان تمضي شهرا
كاملا مع ست دقائق فقط من 26 الشمس نعم ست
دقائق فقط وهو رقم قياسي تاريخيا سجلته
موسكو في شهر ديسمبر عام 2017 وغياب الشمس
قد يكون اكثر ما يفسر غياب الابتسامه عن
محيي الروس اضافه الى معتقدهم الثقافيه
الراسخ بان الضاحكه من دون سبب من قله
الادب لكن القصه تتعقد اكثر فاكثر فما
ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض لا تختفي الغيوم
بل يختفي الثلج وهنا القصه حيث يؤكد
العلماء ان الثلج جاي يمكن ان يحد من
قساوته بالشمس لانه يعكس الضوء
لينشر النور وينشر كثيرا من شظايا الفرح
في موسم الكابه روسيا شانها شان باقي شعوب
البلاد البارده تعاني من الاكتئاب وتعالج
الداء بالدواء حين وبدائي احيانا وبين
الداء والدواء يستعيد اهل موسكو شيئا من
ادبي دستيفكي ويتذكرون قوله كل مظهرت
الشمس ان تعيش من دون امل هو ان تتوقف عن
الحياه او بالاحرى كما يقال بالروسيه